where do you get your strength from i
got this question from one of my twitter
readers who wrote in to say how do you
do it where do you find your strength to
keep doing all these big things
it's interesting because as an
entrepreneur i love being an
entrepreneur because i can create my own
lifestyle i can shape my own destiny i'm
not responding to
somebody who's telling me what to do i
get to shape my own life and i think
that's one of the biggest excitements
that you get as an entrepreneur if
you're doing something that you love
and you're working on big projects that
excite you
at least for me i find it easy to get
the strength and energy to do it
i don't find myself forcing myself to do
very much in my business if i'm forcing
myself to do something then i either
have to eliminate it automate it or
delegate it to somebody else
usually for a lot of the projects that
i'm working on i'll start off doing
everything i hate spending money until
i'm making money so in a new project
i'll pour myself into it i'm doing
everything for the business for this new
project even if it probably doesn't make
sense for me to do everything i don't
have the skills and i'll build it up to
a point where i can figure out this is
something that we can run with and make
money with and we're going to continue
doing it's important to keep doing or
it's not
and at that point i'll hand it off to
somebody to do most of the work or i'll
i'll ditch it like this was a failed
experiment i have tons of failed
experiments
and so i'm always working on
new projects i don't find myself doing
too much of the same thing over and over
and over and over again
unless i really enjoy it like these
videos i've been doing them for i don't
know how long now a number of years i
guess and getting more and more
dedicated to it
every wednesday i set aside time
to make these videos and i answer your
questions and i share what i think is
important and i love doing it
it's one of the best parts of my week
and i only do it because i love it you
know i might sit down and record 20
videos at a time and for a lot of people
that's like that may be crazy it's like
how do you 20 videos i can't even do one
it
just it kills me to do one video i hate
it i don't look forward to it at all
if you're forcing yourself to do
something you're not going to have great
results you're not going to have a lot
of energy into it right you're burning
your energy thinking about how bad this
thing is going to be
so
i get my strength and my energy from
doing projects that i love doing and
surrounding myself with people who i
love working with
and doing something that's worth doing
right like i'm not doing this
because i want to make a lot of money i
make money through this but it's not my
main goal i do it because i love helping
entrepreneurs and most of the stuff
that i create is free and and takes up
my time but i i love doing it it's i i
love seeing entrepreneurs start reaching
their goals and start making
breakthroughs in their personal lives i
love it it inspires me when when i see
your comments on these youtube videos
that makes me want to get up and record
more videos i just love doing it and so
you have to find something that you love
you've got to find something that you
are
passionate about that you can pour
yourself into that you can lose track of
your day you know you start at nine in
the morning and you look up and it's 36
at night and you don't know where your
date went because you you've been
pouring yourself into it
that's not going to happen every day
with your business this is definitely
going to be slow moments and painful
moments and and it's hard i know i get
it but
at least i find that when i'm working on
projects that excite me that that i know
is we're doing for the right reason
that's going to change people's lives
and and the bigger the projects are
often easier to get excited about
because it's going to have a big impact
right you don't get excited by little
projects i don't get excited by
answering one email right i don't get
excited by day-to-day grind kind of
stuff but that's hard i get decided by
the bigger things the new projects the
big picture stuff that's the most
exciting
time at least i guess in my day and so
the more that you can focus on the more
you're bringing of yourself to your
business the more passionate you are
about the work that you're doing the
easier it is to find the strength
to keep going to make it better to put
something new into it every day and when
you are not only focused on the money
life opens up and your business opens up
and you start making different decisions
and and better decisions for your
business and for you
and you'll feel more fulfilled you'll
have a greater impact and you'll end up
making more money
believe
great question for those of you watching
you like the video please give it a
thumbs up below it always makes me want
to do more for you and if you have a
comment about this video or a question
for your own business leave it below in
the comment section as you heard in this
video i love seeing those coming that's
what keeps me motivated that's what
gives me my strength to keep going so
you're doing me a favor by leaving a
comment i love to see those come in
thank you so much and i'll see you soon